la lave n'y arriveront jamais ça me
paraît impossible
tu poses toi qui avait tant de choses à
faire mais bien sûr que non julie tiens
regarde analystes regardent la regarde
la mienne bonjour tous les deux comment
allez-vous mal mal mal mal
non vraiment casimir ce n'est pas le
moment de venir nous poser des questions
stupides
m'enfin calmez-vous que se passe-t-il et
bien la demande de monsieur du snob
nous avons accepté julie et moi de faire
le grand nettoyage annuel du jardin y
il ya tellement de choses à faire que
nous ne savons pas par quel bout
commencer
eh bien là c'est tout oui eh bien on
voit bien que ce n'est pas toi qui à le
faire enfin si si vous étiez plus
détendu vous verriez les choses d'un
autre oeil
casimir ça suffit casimir vraiment tu
commences à nous énerver et informez
vous justement a mis au point de
nouvelles méthodes pour se relaxer
c'est à dire se détendre et être de
bonne humeur
si vous voulez je vais vous en faire
profiter venez j'ai justement apporter 2
16 l'ombre des chaises longues
alors que nous sommes en train grand jeu
qui nous met la pagaille maman me lança
ne sont pas des pagailles ce sont des
chaises longues traces noires mais de
toute façon casimir avec le travail qui
nous attendent pas question de faire de
la chaise longue
écoutez je vous propose un marché vous
apprenez ma méthode et je fais le
travail reprend place ça c'est vrai ça
ouais
allez venez voilà je vais vous apprendre
à vous détendre les croyez moi ils en
avaient bien besoin
voilà ça alors m'asseoir dans une chaise
longue je veux bien moi aussi casimir si
tu fais le travail à ma place alors la
première chose
allons-y dhien bougeant gens bien
allongée voilà le libre a relaxé les
bras détendu tombant le long du corps
c'est maintenant lentement inspirez
expirez inspirez expirez voilà vous êtes
léger vous ne pensez plus à rien vous
êtes jugés comme des déliquants des
venus respirer lentement et que les
gravières détendue voilà royer s'est
tous un bon maintenant julien mentalist
va faire le travail à sa place à la voix
si casimir
merci à la fin c'est vraiment chic de ta
part casino ne parle pas détendez vous
bon alors première chose
ranger tous les rayons du cul en ce
moment ça c'est vraiment pas très
difficile ça va être vite fait qu il ya
vraiment pas de quoi fouetter un chat
ne penser à rien respirer
faire le vide en soit expiré
maintenant il faut que je balaye toutes
les années du bord de mer quel travail
d'une poussière pas là il ya au moins ça
n'a pas été fait inspiré à françois je
me sens beaucoup plus calme
expirez mes idées s'éclaircissent tu
sais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour m
voilà c'est terminé mais que font ces de
paresseux ils se sont endormis
réveillez-vous réveillez-vous
que se passe-t-il mais toi mais qui est
là enfin c'est moi quasiment je crois
que ma méthode vous à réussir
parfaitement alors nous sommes
merveilleusement calme et détendue au
pleine forme pour continuer notre petit
sonia continue et ne venez pas vous non
pas été trop dur à faire quasi me non
non on va tous ces gens je me sens le
courage d'en faire encore le double à
ses vrais casimir oui où tu sais je dois
je crois ça à ma super décontraction
très bien fort leur sied casimir tout à
l'heure aux parts au duo oublier ma
liste il ya dessus exactement le double
de ce que julie a werther quoi ah non
non non c'est pas possible non
nous des gens sont comme du coteau des
braves comme moi pauvre tu les jeunes de
là
[Musique]